salut
[Musique]
juin 2010 neuf aéroports
montréal-trudeau sindia gagner et judith
car on se rencontre pour la première
fois pourtant elle s'apprête à vivre
ensemble une expérience des plus intimes
stressé mais
suit me sens comme presque libérée eto'o
judith jeu contente de la saint louis
parce que je souffrais la nuit est
incroyablement elles s'en vont à saint
louis au missouri pour cacher rue rejet
le retire un dispositif médical qui leur
empoisonne la vie comme ça va vous
coûter d'aller la bonne argent canadien
cimetière 23500 dollars exactement là un
coup tout terminé et vous judith ça vous
monte à peu près 18 mai comme une
trentaine de québécoises depuis quelques
mois
cynthia gagner et judith carole ont
choisi de dépenser beaucoup d'argent aux
états unis plutôt que de se faire opérer
au québec
j'ai décidé la scène oui parce que je
veux ressentir sur mes deux jambes puis
je veux vraiment être capable de vivre
ma vie les femmes que nous avons
rencontrées vivre une crise de confiance
envers ce qui pourrait les opérer au
québec
nous allons tenter de comprendre
pourquoi
mais bonne chance pour vos opérations
aux parle après la chirurgie qui est d'1
3 jours
[Musique]
j'ai mal vraiment dans les n gog super 5
dh
je me sens comme une femme de 70 ans
nous avons fait un premier reportage sur
l'histoire de cynthia gagné en mars 2019
comme des milliers de canadiennes chaque
année en 2015
la jeune femme s'était fait implanter
une bandelette de plastique sous
l'urètre pour traiter un problème
d'incontinence à l'effort
on lui avait dit que ce dispositif
médical faisait des miracles sans lui
dire que chez 10% des femmes environ
il entraînait des complications des
complications parfois dramatiques mon
combo c'est de trouver quelqu'un qui va
m'enlever cette bande est là
le problème c'est que les bandelettes ne
sont pas conçus pour être enlevé très
rapidement elle se greffe aux tissus aux
muscles et parfois au zoo en conséquence
la plupart des médecins sont formés pour
les poser mais pas pour les enlever et
quand les problèmes surviennent il n'y a
pas de consensus médical sur la façon de
les régler en un push sait plus à qui
faire confiance
nous avions sa compagne et cynthia chez
plusieurs urologue québécois qui lui
avait offert des traitements différents
injection de cortisone retrait partiel
de la bandelette ou retrait complet une
chirurgie invasive et risque est
proposée par une urologue qui disait en
avoir fait quelques unes seulement
j'angoisse on peut à savoir ce que est
ce que c'est ce que je vais prendre la
bonne décision
nous avions aussi accompagné cynthia à
saint louis au missouri où pratiquer le
docteur dionisio véronique est à nouveau
gynécologue spécialisée dans le retrait
de bandelettes
il m'assure que je dois absolument
enlever la bande est au complet et ne
pas l'enlever partiellement au printemps
dernier cynthia gagner ne se doutait pas
de lan de choc notre reportage à les
provoquer elle venait tout juste de
fonder un groupe de soutien sur facebook
en quelques jours j'ai été bombardé de
400 messages en attente personnel j'ai
eu des téléphones à la maison pour des
gens qui cherchait de l'aide
six semaines après la diffusion nous
avons retrouvé cynthia gagner à ottawa
elle était accompagnée de sept membres
de son groupe de soutien
qu'est ce qui te le plus frappé depuis
la diffusion de l'émission a fait c'est
la douleur des femmes c'est la
ressemblance de nos cinq angles des
femmes douleur qui sont tout seuls
chacun de leur côté
on voit des histoires vraiment ce que
doha
des médecins qui sarko vraiment quoi
faire avec les patients
dans quelques minutes les huit femmes
ont rendez vous avec des représentants
de santé canada on est ici aujourd'hui
pour vraiment représenter la situation
la problématique des vendeurs de
confiance on va aussi leur démontrer que
les médecins et sont vraiment dans le
déni souhaita à nos déclarations et
femmes se font dire que leur douleur
encore rapport avec l'art avec leurs
balais
on ne nous a pas permis d'assister aux
témoignages des femmes
mais quelques semaines plus tard
certaines d'entre elles sont venues nous
raconter leur histoire en compagnie
d'autres femmes
[Musique]
tous les matins moi je pleure elle pas
je m'éclatais palmer ça coulait le sait
les gens du rpt et ma douleur
ça faisait mal ça faisait très mal mais
ça faisait comme s'ils comprenaient des
lames de couteaux d'un jeune puis au
dessus des zones où ce que la bande et
été installés mab angleterre et
versements nurit savez fait des pierres
de la qualification au tour puis ce
succès infectées sous marche mais sa
satire d'un côté alors seul et libre 7
se développent les tendinites les
médecins disent que les complications
sont rares pourtant dans le groupe
facebook de cynthia il y a près de 600
femmes qui se disent blessés par leur
bandelettes 365 d'entre elles ont
répondu à un sondage maison qui met en
lumière les symptômes les plus fréquents
douleur lors de relations sexuelles
48 % des répondantes difficultés à
marcher 46% difficultés à rester assise
longtemps 42% douleurs chroniques au zen
35% douleurs chroniques aux hanches 33%
infections urinaires à répétition 32%
la plupart de ces complications
potentielles sont répertoriés dans les
brochures des fabricants de bandelettes
et dans des avis publiés par santé
canada
pourtant beaucoup de femmes affirment
sur le groupe facebook que les médecins
ne les reconnaissent par lorsqu'elles se
présentent
moi j'ai passé des irm des crises de ce1
et ont totalisé arthrose arthrite
j'avais rencontré mon neurologue en
janvier avant l'émission
puis il m'a fait des tests pdi la
bandelette il ya aucun rapport des
douleurs mécanique sa part rapport avec
la bande lettre vous arrêtez vos deux
examens le chemin ici pour trouver des
solutions parce que ma douleur la
bandelette je le sais c'est ça après
avoir vu notre premier reportage sans
même reconsulter ou tenir compte de
l'avis de ruraux log toutes ces femmes
ont décidé de se faire retirer leur
bandelettes complètement
elle devait choisir entre des urologues
québécois qui ont fait peu de retrait
complet et luro gynécologue américain
dionisio véronique qu'est ce qui dit en
avoir fait autour de 800 je voyais pas
comment quelqu'un qui a fait quelques
opérations d'enlèvement demande l'aide
pouvait compétitionner avec un docteur
véronique est selon moi c'était il y
avait aucune chance à prendre
il était hors de question que je le
fasse rare au québec
elles ont été les 6 premières patientes
québécoise du docteur véronique hills
elle ne doutait pas de la compétence des
urologues québécois mais elle ne se
sentait pas rassurés par le fait qu'il
semblait avoir fait peu de retrait
complet un peu stressant c'est la bonne
nouvelle de jésus les après l'opération
dans un hôtel de saint louis
cynthia boucle sa valise pour se rendre
à l'hôpital dans
1h25
bye bye on devrait se donner bientôt
comment ça s'est passé
ce n'était pas une bonne place un cordon
a été difficile à retrouver pour une
séance ya deux mais trois matches sur
ippon track and titre à interlagos
il était encore trop tôt pour savoir si
la chirurgie allait définitivement
libéré cimetière de ses douleurs mais
déjà elle était convaincue que les
milliers de dollars qu elle venait de
verser au docteur véronique s était un
bon investissement
il ya fait l'impossible et on le vus de
la bandelette j'ai vu des bandes être
retirée si au québec
cette photo qui a beaucoup circulé dans
le groupe de cynthia at elle raison de
faire peur aux québécois la ramq je dois
reconnaître que pour le moment il n'y a
aucun chirurgien qui possède
l'expérience nécessaire pour retirer
complètement des vendeurs qui cause des
douleurs
cette déclaration est la revendication
principale de cynthia gagner celle ci ne
remet pas en question la compétence des
urologues québécois elles demandent que
leur manque d'expérience en matière de
retrait complet de bandelettes soit
reconnue
le 27 octobre dernier 82 membres de son
groupe de soutien étaient réunis dans un
hôtel de trois rivières elle arborait
fièrement leurs mots clics
amaechi à mai chez comme dans mèche le
nom anglais qu'on donne aux bandelettes
présente madame que refusent de
rembourser nos chirurgie aux états unis
à ce jour trente et une québécoise sont
allés faire retirer leur bandelettes aux
états unis pour justifier son refus de
rembourser les frais du type de
chirurgie qu'elles ont subi la régie
d'assurance maladie dû québec invoque
que quelques médecins québécois sont
capables d'en faire des semblables
nous nous sommes intéressés à l'histoire
de deux femmes qui se sont fait retirer
leur bandelettes au québec dès la sortie
de l'opération j'avais une douleur
intense comme j'avais jamais eu
j'avais jamais subi une douleur comme ça
dans ma vie lisse brouillard s'est fait
poser une bandelette en 2017
six semaines plus tard elle a toujours
mal lorsqu elle revoit son urologue
aliments référer à un neurologue
j'ai passé des tests en urologie on
disait que tout était correct je veux
noste au pacte j'ai fait de la
physiothérapie de l'acupuncture un
neurologue un orthopédiste médecins en
médecine sportive
jamais personne jeudi c'est votre banque
je dois être personne jamais sept mois
après la chirurgie elle n'en peut plus
elle retourne voir son urologue qui le
jugent en faisait moisson c'est la seule
chose que j'ai pas essayé renversé ça
pour voir ce que ça va donner
son neurologue la réfère à un neurologue
de l'hôpital général juif de montréal et
moi dit la mèche a transpercé le levage
9 opéré et sa presse la bandelette c'est
aussi collé sur un air ce qui cause
probablement la douleur dans la jambe
gauche
l'urologue propose d'enlever la
bandelette complètement c'est ce que
j'en comprends la chirurgie soulage la
douleur intense mais un inconfort
persiste
madame brouillard retourne voir
l'urologue et musées que la neige était
complètement enlevé restait moins d'un
centimètre et que dans aucun temps ce
que ce système moins d'un centimètre là
qu'ils pouvaient causer les problèmes
qu'ils lisent brouillard a des doutes
elles demandent son dossier médical sur
leur apparence à montre qu aux cinq
centimètres de la bandelette qui a été
retiré
sur une bandelette comme dit qu'ils
devraient avoir
en quinze et vingt et un sentiment
madame brouillard se dit qu'elle a sans
doute mal compris
elle reprend rendez-vous et enregistre
la consultation
il faut arrêter de délirer je vous
garantis que c'est pas la mèche il reste
1 cm du côté droit
ce côté gauche il n'y a absolument plus
rien
comme madame brouillard dit à l'urologue
qui lui semble avoir lu dans son rapport
de pathologies que 5 cm de bandelettes
seulement avaient été retirés
il répond qu'il n'a pas le rapport sous
les yeux que ça devrait être beaucoup
plus que ça et il réitère que presque
toute la bandelette a été enlevé ce qui
reste c'est vraiment le petit centimètre
qui traverse le trou obturateur pour ce
qui reste de la mèche n'y pensez plus
j'ai décidé d'aller voir à saint louis
un docteur véronique s est de me faire
opérer madame brouillard n'est pas au
bout de ses surprises
ginette et aurait aussi a eu des
problèmes
immédiatement après la pause de sa
bandelette de que je suis allé au rendez
vous de suivi
j'avais de la difficulté à m'asseoir je
sentais comme un ballon dans mon vente
un gros un confort comme si quelque
chose coince et l'urologue de madame
théorêt la réfère à une urologue de
l'hôpital maisonneuve rosemont à l'eau
tout de suite fait un examen
gynécologique
puis alors constaté que a touché la
bande du bout de ses doigts
la bandelette à perforer la paroi
vaginale l'urologue propose un retrait
partiel de quelques centimètres en me
réveillant j'avais les mains manjula
apport que j'avais pu mon ballon mais
tout mais aux douleurs aux jambes
alem c'était la même chose l'urologue
suggère d'opérer à nouveau pour enlever
les quelques 20 cm de bandelettes qui
reste sa très peu près deux semaines
pour que les douleurs reviennent donc
que je me rende compte que j'avais
encore les douleurs aux jambes a montré
la photo puis si c'était plus cher quand
vous avez vu la photo de la bandelette
de cynthia comment vous avez réagi
j'épuré c'est pas comparer elle alors tu
vois toute la bande l'ofppt intacte mois
on la voit pas du tout c'est une simple
des chaires convoi le pire c'est que la
saga n'est pas terminée
un petit bout de bandelettes laisser en
place vient de perforer à nouveau la
paroi vaginale de madame théorêt
urologue propose de ne pas tenter un
troisième retrait pour le moment
elle prescrit un traitement de cortisone
un irm et un suivi un mois plus tard
moi j'ai l'impression que je suis déjà
dans le fond un condamné je ne sais pas
si
une autre intervention va pas régler mon
problème
qu'en est il des québécoises qui ont
opté pour un retrait aux états unis en
octobre au rassemblement des as mais
chez nous avons croisé certaines d'entre
elles
li na a perdu de la force dans une jambe
à cause de la chirurgie de retrait et se
fit luce a encore des douleurs dans les
jambes mais les trois femmes ont
retrouvé leur bien être quelle douleur
mécaniques sont disparus j'ai rien rien
rien de ça ça va se parler mais j'avais
des burettes perforé donc
de ce côté là tout amène guéri aucun
problème ça va ça pour ça vient c'est la
libération tata joue super yen s'affiche
à ma retraite et se fit lui c'est
annabelle ont demandé à la ramq eu de
rembourser les frais de leur chirurgie
clara mme qu a refusé en rappelant entre
autres que des médecins québécois sont
capables de faire la chirurgie sur la
courte liste selon nos sources le
colloque qui a opéré lise brouillard le
hologue qui a opéré ginette théorêt est
une autre rowluck réputé du centre
hospitalier universitaire de sherbrooke
le schuss
trois médecins en qui beaucoup de femmes
ont perdu confiance
à cause de ce qui circule sur le groupe
facebook
dans le cas de l'urologue du chuss elle
affirme avoir fait peu de retrait
complet et dans des enregistrements de
consultation que nous ont fait parvenir
deux patientes
elle déclare que les bandelettes retirer
complètement mesure de 11 à 13 cm cette
information fait craindre aux femmes que
c'est urologue ne fait pas de véritable
retrait complet 11 à 13 cm c'est
beaucoup plus court que les bandelettes
retiré par les trois experts que nous
avons consultés nous avons obtenu les
rapports de pathologie des 30
québécoises qui sont allés à saint louis
la longueur moyenne de leurs bandelettes
de type t'es ôter les bandelettes les
plus courtes était de 20 cm pour se
plier de l'urologue de l'hôpital
maisonneuve rosemont
cette photo de la bande l'aide qu'elle a
retiré à ginette théorêt a fait grimper
l'appréhension sur le groupe facebook
nous avons consulté un expert français
pour savoir si les femmes avaient raison
d'avoir peur lorsque j'ai vu là l'image
j'ai pas été particulièrement
impressionné par l'importance des tissus
et des chairs qui était au contact de la
bandelette
docteur xavier gamme et urologue nous a
été présenté comme l'un des experts
français du retrait de bandelettes
c'est pas parce qu'il ya de la chair
autour de la bandelette que forcément ça
va avoir des conséquences et des
circuits pour le docteur gamme et cette
photo n'a dit pas que le retrait a fait
du tort à madame t aurais je pense pas
je peux enfin en réalité je pense que
initialement surtout s'il avait des
douleurs à type de brûlures ou
d'échauffement d'emblée après la prise
en a mis en place de la bandelette ça
c'est tout à fait évocateur en fait de
lésions d'euros gêne donc dans ce cas là
ça peut être la pause qui a créé les
douleurs persistantes
exactement pour ce qui est de l'urologue
de l'hôpital général juif c'est lui qui
avait affirmé alice brouillard qui ne
lui restait qu'un centimètre de
bandelettes
il y a trois mois madame brouillard
s'est fait opéré par le docteur
véronique s ur lot de madame brouillard
avait laissé sept centimètres de
bandelettes à gauche et 10 cm à droite
il est important d'être formés au
retrait d'une part et d'en faire
régulièrement pour voir le faire
justement correctement et complètement
parce que quelqu'un qui en fait une fois
de temps en temps ne va pas forcément
avoir l'habitude et être capable
d'enlever la bandelette dans sa
globalité
si les urologues québécois ont moins
d'expérience en matière de retrait
complet
c'est en partie parce qu'il privilégie
le retrait partiel qui peut être
indiquée dans certains cas leur lot de
lys brouillard n'a pas donné suite à nos
demandes d'entrevue
l'urologue du chuss et celle de madame
théorêt ont décliné même chose pour
l'association des neurologues du québec
dans une lettre elle déclare à propos de
la pose de bandelettes que ses membres
vivent quotidiennement les succès de
cette chirurgie qui transforme
positivement la vie de patientes
incontinentes elle ajoute qu une
excision partiel peut s'avérer
nécessaire et que celle ci est pratiqué
par plusieurs zéros log dans les cas
beaucoup plus rare nécessitant une
excision complète les patientes n'ont
pas besoin d'aller ailleurs que ce type
de chirurgie a été réalisée avec succès
au québec
nous avons soumis l'ensemble de notre
dossier au collège des médecins
on est très préoccupée par des femmes
qui souffrent présentement il faut faire
quelque chose
le collège a décidé de déclencher une
enquête il va faire une recherche de
fonds sur le sujet
rencontrer des experts et des patientes
étudier les dossiers médicaux de
patientes et interroger leur chirurgien
docteur robert demande un peu de
patience aux femmes
la seule chose si on peut par une
nouvelle problème immédiatement on va
trouver une solution dans un proche
avenir
c'est ce que je souhaite c'est ceux
d'enfants seront travaillés le travail
d'enquêté devrait aboutir à des
recommandations et des normes de
pratique pour la question c est y
aurait-il mieux par exemple de
concentrer dans une seule équipe qui en
fait plus les soins de celle de cette
nature là qu'ils exigent
je ne
des techniques en attendant les
résultats de l'enquêté
le collège étudie la possibilité
d'intervenir auprès de la ram cul pour
qu'elle reconsidère son refus de
rembourser tous les retraits complet
fait aux états unis on peut faire
certainement une suggestion une
recommandation l'a vaincu mais il va
falloir vraisemblablement que le
gouvernement autorise ce paiement auprès
de la même que c'est la mineuse la santé
pour intervenir exact la ministre de la
santé daniel mais cannes nous a écrit
qu'elle allait laisser le collège mener
ses travaux et faire ses recommandations
à la régie de l'assurance maladie du
québec
avant d'intervenir à ce jour le
gouvernement de l'ontario à rembourser
les frais de chirurgie aux états unis
d'au moins une quinzaine de patientes
il y a quelques semaines
la première ministre de l'écossé a
ordonné une enquête sur leurs traites
bandelettes quand il a été révélé que
trois écossaise avait vécu des histoires
similaires à celles de lise brouillard
la première ministre du pays a
personnellement invité le docteur
véronique skis à réopéré ces trois
femmes à venir faire un séjour en écosse
pour faire des opérations et former les
chirurgiens écossais nous avons revu
cynthia gagner tout récemment ce n'était
plus la femme souffrante que nous avions
connu il y à ozoir un petit polar à la
hanche que ça va vraiment bien j'ai
recommencé à bouger à faire du sport
pour vraiment bien honnêtement elle est
même montée
de montagne dans les dernières semaines
vraiment content
[Musique]